peu
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
ah oui
on
[Musique]
non
on n'est jamais mort thierry alors là
oui leur admis depuis
faire un film à tendance
[Musique]
quel moment joue au flipper dans la
journée il ya deux guerres de guildes
moment enfin de préférence quand même le
soir ce fut un délassement après le
travail c'est à peu près le seul moment
vraiment on a le temps
s'intéresser à ça le matin on va au
travail du bois -4 1 me dis il faut
faire son petit casse croûte pour manger
on fait sa petite sieste
le soir on a tout le temps quand samedi
ou dimanche
surtout dans les moments de loisirs
j'adore
depuis l'âge de 13 14 ans à peu près
comme ans à cette époque j'étais gosse
je me souviens pas très bien j'étais
gosse tu arrives une histoire quand on
était jeune avec cellex c cette histoire
wayne on est tout simplement parce que
ce n'était pas très riche alors une même
de l'idée de confectionner des décisions
en carton c'est je tombe ma foi je les
ai utilisés jusqu'au moment le patron
s'est aperçu quand même que tu vois pas
jouer éternellement sans passer à la
caisse il avait l'habitude de séjour bon
j'étais facilement repérer
il a donc ouvert le tiroir caisse de
l'appareil a retrouvé ses jetons il
m'emmenait dans l'ariège seul jeu m'a
fouillé les prochains à trouver quelques
centaines
[Musique]
bon clippers un pompiste qui envoya
nouveau thème ça se retrouve à son
regard il ya le regard glisser ce
sociaux labit une typo la vie des yeux
la travaillent là on voit qu'il n'ya pas
nous rejoindre les joueurs qui ne savent
pas jouer qui se contentent de lancer la
[ __ ] essaye de les taper
cela n'arrive résultat si ce qui
m'aurait une formule tout soit bon
joueur lui joue pour plaisir de jouer et
effectue ses cales des contrôles
[Musique]
non
pour le trophée du joueur j'appelle ça
la danse des flips enfin le clip des
joueurs s'assurant boulet la vi e place
on a toujours un geste à droite ou à
gauche vous alors un jeu de jambes vous
sont simples c'est quelquefois le coin
qui se lève beaucoup de choses hein
c'est ce jeu suivant le moment c'est
l'habit labidi joue mais le joueur joue
avec la vie
keeper c'est pas un jeu d'isoler un jeu
et solitaire alors on se crée une
famille quand on quand on est seul dans
la vie on se ferait une famille on se
cherche des amis à droite à gauche
partant de la plupart en
considère-t-elle tel ou tel comme son
frère son père
suivant le cas là
les amis on rester seul
[Musique]
il est gay
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
un bon joueur ne dépose chaque route de
l'argent on dépense de l'argent un bon
joueur un sens sont relativement des
îles en langage de 5 francs 10,10 francs
non non j'ai une bonne soirée toutefois
plusieurs quêtes bord 3 3 4 tourner en
rond quatre matins on voit la belote le
tarot ou n'importe quel autre jeu
[Musique]
on vient forcément la bonne dit l'habit
qui fait un score favorable ya la
mauvaise dit ce qui passe entre les
jambes l'heure qu'à ce moment-là il
précède pas mal de noms d'oiseaux
c'est toujours l'aspect qui la [ __ ]
cette liste et repos je fais souvent au
compteur le flux peuvent être un jeu de
mots oui c'est certain je joue mal je
crois que c'est ça démontre une certaine
force de certaines franges des strictes
et accède à la finale fois la force
musculaire justement pour remuer ces
appareils qui sont relativement l'eau
dans ma foi elle se contente de jouer la
bi bien souvent d'ailleurs elle joue et
joue même mieux que les hommes se
contentent de lancer la bbc où elle se
terminer
ça s'arrête là
[Musique]
et tu viens et petits allez viens je
suis la vahiné que tu n'as pas vu la
fille manqué le rendez vous tardifs
non je suis la seule pièce le coeur sans
du le clan faire bien je t'aime petit au
monde des secrets viens je suis la femme
universelle que tu introduis d'une pièce
c'est ton pays
je vibre genou et je jouis de temmar qui
est en direct
je suis une femme américaine je suis un
truc américain que les aura vus sang de
tes yeux tu ne pourra plus vivre sans
mes couleurs qui ne pourraient plus être
dans mes tribulations
m
un flipper moulay ce serait comme une
télévision sur une colonne de 3000 sont
par exemple alors au plus d'intérêt on
ne regarde que le fils donc on en jouant
ce sera souvent à trith on en entend les
bruits et les dictées qui allait trop
petit il marche ca fait du goût du potin
débutants et compteur qui tourne bon
mentalement le joueur lui calcule ses
promesses qu'ils peuvent regarder en
même temps et ses conteurs et son jeu
l'autre sens et l'importance les ir d'un
flipper tout plutôt po et tous les
spectateurs
j'ai une attirance parce que finalement
il faut qu'on est devant le jeu les plus
que la boule jacky si on te disait que
le keeper n'existe plus pour exister
plus on n'y aurait plus de possibilités
d'amusement la tournée dans un café pour
l'inventaire s'ils n'existaient plus
les fois précédentes il y en a qu à
partager pour en dollar ont valu tromper
thébaux à 2,15 c'est même pas la peine
que jean sa deuxième intoxiqué de
flipper attend que les canons supporter
aux clippers
non je vous le plaisir mais ça serait
pas mal au dos je ne joue pas tu
pourrais jouer au keeper ailleurs que
dans un café mais j'ai l'impression que
je pourrais jouer au flipper aussi bien
dans la rue si si ça existe et plein
milieu d'un champ
ça me dérange la presse joue beaucoup
mieux dans un ambiance bistrot les deux
groupes
[Musique]